taylor swift drops a surprise album that
has her going in a completely different
direction
but the secret messages are still there
so who is she taking aim at now
here is folklore
[Music]
stripped decoded and full of secrets
folklorist taylor's eighth studio album
the first to be classified as
alternative
a friend is a friend
fan theory number one is swift's
boyfriend of three years co-wrote
two songs on the album william bowery is
credited along with swiss long-time
collaborators
since there is no record of a songwriter
by that name
super sleuths think it's joe alwyn
pointing to the fact that william is the
name of his great grandfather who was a
composer
and the bowery hotel is where the couple
first connected
but you won't find any love songs
dedicated to joe on folklore
instead most are breakup songs leading
others to wonder if
many of the emotional lyrics
are actually pointed at one-time bestie
carly claus
seven hours before the album drop carly
posted this video to instagram
yup right there it says easter egg
you never know what it's gonna be
another fan theory
taylor just revealed the name of blake
lively and ryan reynolds third daughter
the girl's name has been a secret since
her arrival last summer
but in the song betty taylor sings the
names inez
and james which belong to blake and
ryan's other daughters
so is betty the third betty i won't make
assumptions
taylor says i found myself not only
writing my own stories but also
of people i've never met people i've
known or those i wish i hadn't
hmm is she talking about scooter braun
some fans think mad woman may be about
their much publicized battle over her
album masters
and the taylor is taking aim at
scooter's wife yale
after she defended
my him all firing at your yacht
others believe the song is a dig at kim
kardashian west
saying she did the dirty work for
husband kanye by making his 2016
private conversation with taylor public
[Music]
and what about this eagle-eyed fans were
quick to screenshot a sweatshirt
that's part of taylor's new merch note
the price
51.50 this week kanye tweeted that kim
wanted to put him on a
5150 psych hold the price didn't stay
that way for long
it was changed to 51.49
not long after fans noticed
[Applause]
[Music]